digital marketing is crucial for our
business and digital age company needs
experts industrial marketing to stay
ahead of the competition upscale in
industrial marketing not only help
individuals Advance their careers but
also boost business online presence
sales and audience engagement I have
taken four courses from Simply done the
latest on being the empty ghaziabad
National marketing program and my
overall income increased by 50 after
completion of this course hi I am Vijay
Kumar Pathak I am a digital marketing
manager where I work in export
Department creating brand awareness
through digital marketing for
international market I've also trained
over 100 plus students and helped them
become expert in this marketing field I
teach digital marketing remotely at
various institutes across the country
simply learn has been a huge part of my
personal digital marketing company so
far I have taken four courses from
Simply run so far including the digital
marketing certified associate the
digital marketing expert master program
the business analyst expert master
program and the latest one the IMT
ghaziabad marketing program what I like
the most about IMT ghaziabad program
was the live session they were quite
interactive and I could watch recording
lectures at my own convenience if I
missed any classes the course content
was in-depth and the ebook provided is
also very helpful
simply learn Branch value is just
excellent in the job market as well in
the long run I want to become an expert
industry marketing field and help my
employers clients as well as students to
grow exponentially and I think
upskilling and keep my skills and
knowledge up to date is the only way I
will be able to stay on track to achieve
my goals apart from work I love
traveling listening to good music
learning and exploring new things
learning the latest techniques and tools
health professionals enhance their
skills and stay ahead in that state with
technology and consumer Behavior
involving constantly upskilling is
essential for any digital marketing
professional stay competitive
[Music]